سوره الحرب تبقى باهظه مهما اختلفت
سياقاتها والحال لا يختلف في السودان التي
تعيش وطاه الحرب منذ ازيد من 25 يوما
الخطر المحدق بالبلاد الان في ظل استمرار
المعارك هو امكانيه تفشي الاوبئه فمنظمه
الصحه العالميه دقت ناقوس الخطر بخصوص
الوضع الصحي في السودان محذره من تفشي
الملاريا وحمى الضنك والحصبه في البلاد
الامر لم يتوقف عند هذا الحد بل نبهت الى
ان ملايين الاطفال والسيدات الحوامل
يعانون من سوء التغذيه الحاد وكشفت
المنظمه ان 70% من المنشات الصحيه في
المناطق المتاثره بالقتال بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع خرجت عن الخدمه ما
يهدد بانهيار القطاع الصحي في البلاد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه
والاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات